[Music]
recently some said photos of the
shooting of sonic the hedgehog 2 did the
rounds
on it you can see sonic's companion
knuckles this confirms the appearance of
the popular character as there were
already some rumors about the echidna
last year one picture even shows sonic
tails and knuckles at the same time
similar to the shooting of the first
sonic but his statures
besides that a photo proves that actors
james marston and tikka sumter are
coming back allegedly
there are plans for aquaman star jason
momoa to take over the dubbing of
knuckles
but this has not yet been officially
confirmed paramount sonic the hedgehog 2
is set to be released on april 8th 2022
john turtledub's mag from 2018 thrill
fans
not only because of its humor but above
all due to the immense underwater action
once the box office taken quadrupled the
budget it was clear that a second part
centered on the 20 meter long
prehistoric shark was inevitable
since turtle top is no longer available
as director ben wheely has volunteered
to direct the film
in an interview with comicbook.com he
philosophized about having the
opportunity to bring action to the
screen
on an incredibly large scale furthermore
he said he wants to make sure that
shark fans around the globe get their
money's worth
core responsible for this is again the
well-known producer lorenzo di bueno
ventura who shares duties together with
bel avery
and catherine juyong ying the extent to
which the book of the same name by steve
alt will serve as a reference for the
mac 2
is still unclear but it can be assumed
that screenwriters john and eric hobo
will
certainly borrow elements from the 8
part book series it is also uncertain at
this point who else will return to the
screen besides jason stethem
we are eagerly waiting for the news
about the mac 2 and hope that the
theatrical release will be announced
soon
since shooting will start in 2 months
time
following the leaking of growing amounts
of information about the upcoming mcu
adventurer spiderman no way home in
recent weeks and months dug
actor alfred molina recently spoke out
in interview with variety
unusually frankly the meanwhile 67 year
old chat with the trade magazine about
his until then not yet officially
confirmed role as doug ock
and the multiverse in the film he's
going to play the exact same character
as
in samuraimy spider-man 2. lots of fans
will still remember the end
when he apparently sacrificed himself on
the hudson river this is exactly where
no way home is meant to pick up because
as molina explains
dugoc actually didn't die in this scene
which is why this scene will be resumed
in the new film
in order for this to run smoothly molina
has to be digitally rejuvenated since
between spider-man 2 and no way home
well they're almost 15 years apart
another surprising aspect
is the importance of his role in the new
mcu film and it's not going to be just a
small appearance by any means
on the one hand we have a spider-man
whose identity is known to the whole
world and on the other hand we have a
duck aqua has to deal with the collapse
of the multiverse especially the latter
would be perfect for an introduction of
doctor strange
who has already been more or less
confirmed this meeting of different
worlds is then of course predestined for
the various villains first and foremost
duck and electro who then in turn have
to be fought by various spider-man
therefore spider-man no way home can be
seen as a sequel to samurai spider-man 2
mark raps
the amazing spider-man 2 and john wants
spider-man far from home
all at once plus the rumors are still
circulating that willem the foe will
appear as green goblin charlie cox's
daredevil if this side murphy's
multiverse is to be believed
jon favreau will also return as happy
hogan that's one of the less surprising
pieces of news though
after all by the end of far from home
there's plenty to suggest that he
and aunt may are a couple not to mention
that he makes a pretty good surrogate
father for peter parker
so what do you think of these recent
developments are you looking forward to
a more
central role for doc or would you have
preferred someone else like the green
goblin to take the spotlight
feel free to let us know in the comments
spider-man no way home will be released
in theaters on december 17th
2021 in june the shooting of the mad max
fury road prequel around the background
story of the young furiosa will finally
start
at a press conference director george
miller has now revealed how huge the
prequel will actually
be the 76 year old shared a surprise
right at the beginning namely that the
blockbuster like fury road will also be
shot in australia more precisely in new
south wales
also president was gladys berejiklian
the premier of this australian state
she informed those present that mad max
furiosa will be the biggest production
ever shot in australia quite an
announcement after all aquaman and
thorough love and thunder were also shot
down under
in turn this also means that furiosa
will be much bigger than fury road and
not just in terms of production while
fury road covers a period of three days
furiosa is expected to spend several
years lead anchor is anja taylor
yaya abdulmadi in the second and
australian-born chris hemsworth will
provide the perfect atmosphere
in front of the camera while you cannot
probably count on an appearance by
furious star tom hardy
tom hardy as mad max should not be
entirely dismissed however since
director miller has planned further
appearances with him
though not in furiosa the blockbuster
with any utility
is scheduled for release on june 23 2023
in the hbo series game of thrones emilia
clarke was able to wow the masses with
their role as daenerys targaryen
as variety reports the 34 year old is
now headed to the new marvel
project secret invasion where she will
take on an as of yet
unknown role alongside olivia coleman
who was also recently signed on
if the rumor turns out to be true it
would be clark's first role in the mcu
where she would then join coleman as
well as samuel l jackson and ben
mandelson
the content is about skrulls which are
alien shapeshifters that have
infiltrated earth and assumed the
identities of various marvel heroes the
series is not intended to be quite as
big as the comic book however and the
focus will thus not be on the appearance
of as
many marvel characters as possible but
rather on the prevailing paranoid
atmosphere
the project is being produced
exclusively for disney plus and
unfortunately does not yet have a fixed
release date
just a few weeks ago michael keaton
confused many fans when he told deadline
that he was still unsure about his
return
on the flash due to the pandemic now as
reported by the rap magazine it has been
officially confirmed that keaton will be
part of the filming that started on
monday and as expected he will be seen
in his role as
batman the story revolves around the
protagonist's fateful journey to the
past causing massive consequences for
the present
therefore we'll not only get to see
michael keaton but also ben affleck as
batman for the last time
dc's the flash is scheduled for release
on november 4th 2022
it's no secret that a range of streaming
services have benefited from the
pandemic
this is in fact also the case for
netflix which for example got many uses
through
uneventful times just about a year ago
with its documentary series tiger king
in contrast to competitors amazon prime
disney plus and the like
the almost boundless influx of new
customers has now declined drastically
as the first quarterly figures from 2021
show
the formerly almost monopolistic
provider was able to gain only 4 million
new users which means it missed its
actual target of 10 million new
customers
in quarter 1 by far it is slowly but
surely becoming apparent that netflix
will no longer be
able to reproduce the record figures
from last year and is now being left
out in the cold due to the lack of top
class productions
while disney plus for example scores
almost weekly with interesting series
and movie content the californian
company is lagging behind the
competition
in many respects by way of comparison
netflix has just about 208 million users
worldwide while
disney despite its relatively young
streaming service has already cracked
the 100 million user mark
as a result netflix forecasts for the
summer of 2021 are sobering in its
quarterly report and the company has
adjusted its high expectations to just
3.2 million new subscribers in coming
weeks and months
besides the recent disappointing series
and movie offerings many users are upset
about the price increase in many parts
of the world
which is certainly not beneficial for
the acquisition of new customers
however with the launches of the witcher
season 2 don't look up red notice and
many other top-notch productions
netflix should be able to report better
figures in the second half of the year
what do you think are you a netflix
subscriber and if so
are you satisfied with the service or
are you increasingly preferring the
competitors
feel free to discuss this with us in the
comments
[Music]
you